and there is no security everything is a  risk we're here for a very short period  of time so my call to action to  everybody is don't wait until you find  yourself in some existential crisis  because you've been living your life  based upon some you know social rule  book that doesn't fit your own blueprint  instead Embrace what is uniquely you and  have the courage and the fortitude and  the faith to try to bring expression to  that it may be scary and it might  contravene what your parents want for  you and it might seem risky but  ultimately I think the riskiest thing to  do is to play it safe and live your life  in accordance with you know somebody  else's expectations of what you should  do and be